[Music]
welcome back so in this video I'm going
to walk you through why the l1 norm is
so useful for promoting sparse solutions
to linear systems of equations this is
really kind of the geometric picture of
why compressed sensing works and why you
can use the l1 norm for sparsity in
general in robust linear algebra so this
is kind of a cornerstone lecture for
this chapter three of data driven
science and engineering where we're
gonna talk about all of these different
sparse optimization procedures for
robust statistics and robust solution of
systems of equations and for compression
and compress sensing okay so I'm really
excited this is kind of a cool geometric
perspective on sparsity and the l1 norm
so I'm going to start with the l2 norm
which you are familiar with so you know
about the l2 norm in in this example
here I have kind of two coordinates I'm
going to literally just call this let's
call this s1 and we're going to call
this s 2 and the 2 norm is literally the
2 norm of this vector of coefficients s
s1 and s2 the 2 norm is the sum of s 1
squared plus s2 squared square root ok
so this is the the regular norm that
you're used to for any kind of Euclidean
vector space this is just the regular
norm as far as we're concerned ok and
I'm going to walk you through
specifically how this is used to solve
the compress sensing problem so I'm
going to write down in math what we're
trying to solve is y equals theta s so
we know Y we know theta we're solving
for s and this is an undetermined system
of equations so there are infinitely
many S's that satisfy this ok so this is
under determined under determined and so
that means there are infinitely many S's
that satisfy that equation ok and so
what I'm gonna do in in kind of picture
here is I'm gonna walk you
for the 2-norm how you can interpret
this to norm solution and then we're
gonna look at why the one norm is so
good for promoting sparse solutions okay
so let's get started and I'm gonna draw
this in kind of a big cartoonishly large
version of this problem here so again
we're gonna have our two coordinates s1
and s2 and the way you can think about
this system of equations y equals theta
s there's a whole family there's
infinitely many S's that will satisfy
this equation let's say there are
literally two unknowns s1 and s2 and I
only have one measurement y1 okay then
this would define a line in s1 s2 space
okay and so I'm going to define this as
a line that literally satisfies this is
my line of s that satisfies this
equation
okay and when I'm trying to find the
minimum two norm solution so there are
infinitely many S's that satisfy this
equation they live on this line here and
so what we're gonna do is we're gonna
try to find the specific s on this line
that satisfies that's the minimum of
some norm in this case the minimum to
norm is this white dot here okay so this
has the minimum two norm on this family
of solutions and the way I like to think
about this is I'm going to start with
kind of little circles these all of
these points have equal to norm on this
they have equal radius that's what the
two norm is is the radius these all have
equal to norm and I'm going to grow this
until I just intersect this line and
that means that this is the point on the
line that has the minimum to Norman it
has the it intersects the circle of
minimum radius of the smallest radius
every other point intersects a larger
radius and has a larger two norm okay so
this is literally the kind of l2
solution with the smallest radius and
I'm gonna put radius in quotes because
we're going to kind
relax what we mean by radius in a minute
okay so that's literally what we mean
out of all of these infinitely many
possible solutions of s that live on
this line we can find a specific one by
finding the solution that minimizes the
two norm okay and that's what we did in
the singular value decomposition is we
found solutions that minimized the two
norm which intersects this circle with
that line good now what we actually want
to do in compress sensing and in lots of
other applications is we don't want the
the minimum two norm solution s we want
the s that is the sparse aspossible s it
has as many zeros as possible and still
satisfies this equation now generally
that's achieved using this zero norm or
the zero the the s that minimizes the
zero norm and that would intersect this
kind of pink plus sign with my blue
infinite set of solutions s okay and
you'll notice here that if you look kind
of at this white dot where this where my
solution space intersects the minimum
size plus sign it's only pointing in the
s two direction so s 1 is equal to zero
this is a sparse solution okay it has
one of its components equal to 0 and
only one of those components is nonzero
so the L 0 norm promotes sparsity and
this L 0 norm it's not actually
technically mathematically enormous
doesn't satisfy all the conditions that
a norm meets to satisfy but kind of
morally we can use it to measure how far
away we are you know from the origin in
this in this l0 metric so l0 is what we
would actually want to minimize because
that gives you a truly sparse solution
but you can't find the minimum l0 norm
solution using convex optimization this
is an np-hard problem to find this
solution so we can't do that so instead
we use the l1 norm this is why the l1
norm has gotten so much attention in the
last few decades is because the
one norm this you can solve for this
minimum one norm solution in a convex
way meaning it's scales with mores lot
scales to bigger problems efficiently
and it tends to give you a sparse
solution so the the minimum norm
solution in the one norm of this blue
line if you kind of grow these diamonds
grow grow grow grow grow when it
intersects this blue line first it will
typically be at a sparse solution in
this case where s2 is nonzero but s1 is
0 and so this l1 norm often if you solve
for the minimum one norm you happen to
still get the sparseness solution that
would have also satisfied the minimum
zero norm so this is what you want but
this is not computable so instead we use
the one norm which is computable and it
tends to give you sparse solutions when
you minimize that norm ok so again just
to recap this white dot here is the
minimum one norm solution out of all of
these infinitely many possible solutions
this white point has the minimum one
norm so I literally grow these one norm
equal radius diamonds I grow them and I
grow them and I grow them until they
intersect my solution family and that
point happens to be a sparse solution s
it is a solution because it's on this
blue line and it's sparse because one of
the components is equal to zero and the
cool thing is that this actually
generalizes even better in higher
dimensions so the higher dimensions you
go to this kind of analogy works even
better so these diamonds these diamonds
are really pointy and they tend to
intersect underdetermined solution
families at sparse solutions so the one
norm promotes sparse solutions to this
underdetermined problem and that's
really really useful for robust
solutions for finding solutions that are
not too complicated that don't have too
many free parameters lots and lots of
areas machine learning and statistics
and linear algebra where you want sparse
solutions to these problems ok and the
l1 norm is mathematically how we're
going to get those sparse solutions
we're going to find solutions s
that minimize the 1-norm of s okay
that's what we're gonna do and I'll just
show these other ones because it's kind
of fun these are other norms these are I
always joke with my students that this
is a circle in the one norm this square
is a circle in the infinity norm this is
a circle in the four norm and so on and
so forth so your idea of what it is to
be a circle is because you're measuring
distance or radius in terms of this two
norm in terms of this distance here this
kind of Pythagorean type distance okay
whereas if you measure distance in the
taxicab norm right if I'm saying well
it's just as easy for me to get here as
it is for me to get here then that norm
has different circles different equal
distance points okay and so all of these
norms have different circles or
different you know level sets of equal
distance in the one norm
I should write out what the one norm is
for you you probably want to know that
so the one norm of s is literally in
this case the absolute value of s 1 plus
the absolute value of s 2 it's literally
just how much of s 1 and how much of s 2
and that gives you these pointy kind of
diamond shapes in general it would be
the sum of the absolute value of all of
the components of s if this is you know
an N dimensional vector and so on and so
forth you can define you know all of
these norms in in some some way and
these pink curves are the level sets or
the circles in those norms okay great so
I hope I've convinced you that the l1
norm is an extremely useful norm for
promoting sparse solutions of these
underdetermined linear systems and we'll
use that a lot for robusta fiying our
linear regressions for robusta fiying
the SVD and principal components and for
solving the compress sensing problem all
right thank you